hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to and I'm
a ghost yeah I'm a ghost
strangest thing I died last week
watching ghost dad you would have done
the same but if there's anything that
this movie has taught me is that death
is no reason to stop working just keep
going on with your everyday life and
comedic possibilities will fall in your
lap sasparilla
good that of more indeed got you friend
hey Malcolm I'll do my review could you
do that outside why am I doing this
again I told you it's the only way to
continue seeing and hearing me as a
ghost but why there's no rhyme or reason
to it I don't know it just is now go
back to doing jumping jacks dressed as
Gandalf the gray while reciting the
dialogue to Big Lebowski backwards
stressful real good Frank and why do I
have to be dressed as sexy Dorothy while
wearing a sombrero why is there even a
sexy Dorothy costume who the fuck is
turned on by sexy Dorothy I didn't make
up the nonsensical rules of the
afterlife I just know that you - stop
doing that
I'll disappear the review will be over
and both of you will be out of a job
got it this is a bunch of bullshit I'll
pop up in your Dorothy voice
golly gee mr. critic this sure is a lot
of bullshit it's but a small price to
pay to be in the world of the living now
way with you the dead grieve at your
presence I thought I liked him better
dead Dorothy boys yes there's a lot of
crazy rules about the afterlife that
apparently we didn't know about but
they'll sort of the thing in movies for
a while the same way vampires and
zombies has kind of been popular in
media recently ghosts were really
popular in the late 80s and early 90s
presumably starting with the popularity
of ghostbusters after that little
blockbuster suddenly every movie had a
spook Specter or ghost in it all
connecting with either a quirky
afterlife a bizarre haunting or just
about anything with comedic
possibilities well another thing the
late 80s and early 90s liked to do was
combine stuff because we clearly don't
do that nowadays of course under Bill
Cosby who at the time had the number one
TV spot with The Cosby Show for a year
he was clean he was friendly he was a
good role model and he made everybody
laugh that is on television his movie
career continued to tank with bomb after
bomb as Hollywood seemed to be hinting
that unless Cosby can pull off a
successful film with the next one they
were going to yank him as a main star of
the big screen and keep him the main
star of the little screen for the rest
of his life what followed was a movie
career dangling on the edge knocked over
by a spit ball of deafening silence
where there should have been laughter
this is that spit ball directed by
Sidney Poitier yes that's Sidney Poitier
they call me mr. Tibbs he'll be calling
you much worse that do they see this
film ghosts dead is a fascinating
experiment to see if two successful
people re-entering two unsuccessful
fields can somehow produce a successful
not this the answer of course is too
painful to sit through too painful to
talk about and too tempting not to have
me be in pain over so let's take a look
at the final nail in the coffin that
really did make Cosby's movie career a
ghost
this is ghost and we see Cosby in the
very familiar position that most comedic
dads are in not having enough time for
his kids because he's too busy being not
funny with his wife having passed away
from get the bitch out of the film Isis
Cosby finds he has to cut corners by
having recording of himself read his
kids a bedtime story okay honeyBun
that's enough for tonight I had to work
late again this weekend now make me
louder hold me up to the door good night
Diane don't wait up for me
I never do you know if he's so damn busy
with his job at all how did he have time
to record all this couldn't you have
spent that time making the recording to
be with your kids instead daddy can you
come play with me I'm sorry poor thought
but I got do this recording to make up
for the fact that I can't spend time
with you you know it's thinking like
that that makes you do Leonard stick now
we agreed that one dimension
that movie in this house things don't
get much better when he forgets his
oldest daughter's birthday so he puts
shaving cream and a candle on a hat
that ought to solve the problem my
father of my ninth birthday dressed up
in a bunny costume for a whole week
whole week a whole weight because of
zippers stuck you know he didn't mean to
do it so you had to bump around house
with me to be like a bunny for all week
well I'll give this movie this I do
legitimately want to see him dead you
forgot you completely forgot bucko admit
it if everything goes the way I think
the company is also gonna give me a car
and if they do you can have grumpy
really yes really
Oh daddy can I Drive it today oh I
promise I'll be incredibly careful I
would take it you know wow that must be
quite the car that she's excited about
quite the incredible awesome piece of
shit Clark Griswold 'mobile you've ever
seen in your life
hey maybe next week you'll let you
cruise around in that hot rodding
minivan you know the one with too entire
horse powers in it
I was thought well how we used to it and
from here Cosby takes a merry stroll
down nerdy stereotype Lane yes because
this movie is too lazy to steal from
other stereotypes he focuses instead on
just one the 80s nerd and all the
incarnations that this decade pushed out
with it you got the ear chol nerd the
secretary nerd the old relic nerd and of
course the businessmen nerds and for a
comedian who enforced that any person of
any color can be in any position there
sure does seem to be a lot of crusty old
white guys running things aren't there
gentlemen you oh no Elliot Hopper oh
yeah ha ha get you tickling mr. Nero's
wife in Macy's window all bets are off
but things go awry when he stepped into
a cab driven by a crazy cab driver
gonna know fast aren't we Hey junu
basalt and sidewalks across from the
McCallister's house is that way
yeah yeah yeah hey you got two crazy
minutes - oh my god am i go Stan
oh no no no there is no way I'm starting
this horse crap
no no I'm out I'm going to my contract
I'd give you $20 to stop warning I've
got $76 all you have to do stuff to camp
hey come on you're driving so fast me we
lost the drain screen projection behind
us the Lord shake necess mean bin so
looks like the cab driver is a crazy
Satanist typical as Cosby convinces him
that he is Satan himself
ee typical and convinces him to pull the
cab over but just as he sees why white
people should never drive cabs
he opens the car door plunging into the
river he makes his way back up to find
that nobody can see him and apparently
nobody can touch him either this of
course means he comes to a horrible
realization I'm not dead I know I know
I'm not dead
this is I'm dreaming I gotta wake up
wake up wake up uh neck
I gotta get out of the street that's
right he's not very funny in a movie on
his own it desperately needs kids to
work off of I did I did
what daddy you can see me what you can
see me not anything that I can't hear
anything
but in a strange combination of rules
Cosby finds that people can see him in
the dark but not in the light and on top
of that they can't hear him even though
he can hear himself you can't hear me
but you can see me you can't hear me but
I could hear myself also if he
concentrates he can touch stuff but if
he doesn't things float right through
him and if he doesn't keep focus his
voice doesn't match up with his body
mm-hmm and what else what else uh you
don't put him in daylight you don't get
him wet and you don't be the Metra
midnight daddy are you going to go where
like Nathan oh my god oh wow I'm okay
you know it's funny how this ghost movie
is supposed to be funny but in a strange
way it's actually kind of creepier than
scary ghost movies could you just hear
this creepy audio being listened in
something like The Exorcist
oh my god
all oh wow mom's you know how the kids
love jell-o pudding and you know it's
made with fresh milk so it's wholesome
but Cosby it appears as being sucked
into another location via not very well
hidden crane lifts
remember me for my inaudible gibberish
yeah yeah he gets transported to a
genetically spliced version of rowdy
McDowell on the dose X's guy who's a
scientist that puts metal things on his
fingers to sync up his audio why would
that help sync up his audio close to
death I drown and attach again Keith Ann
gives him the beaker of purple liquid
and looks at a compass I don't know why
he's doing that either you know for a
scientist his answer to anything
afterlife related is it just is whoa are
you doing yeah so this movie clearly
thinks that if Cosby places role as a
broken Disney animatronic somehow
that'll get a laugh which if it was a
Disney World
yeah would but here it's just the death
of comedy they screwed up
it's the afterlife equivalent to
misplacing your paperwork it's rare but
it happens and weaves a sort of
speciality of mine you know I've written
a book on it actually inter corporal Mel
trans Holmes
I'm the world's foremost authority on
life after death this is why I'm in no
way going to contact anybody about the
absolute proof that there's life after
death but instead Paul taken a
depressingly unfunny dialogue about
having a girl's name book is spelled
Edith but it's pronounced Edith what's
the girl's name
Edith is a pony's name will you named
after I was named after my grandmama and
they called her Edith no her name is
Edith so you see it is a girl's thing
nice not stand there maybe if we yell
louder this will somehow be funny nope
then why are we still doing it no and
then you could send me back all right so
he sends him back to his family via
lightsaber sound effects
yeah because nobody would recognize that
sound and he tries to figure out what to
do next
Oh am I going to go it'll work wait a
minute
seriously seriously you don't call me
kooky but I think being dead can at
least warn one day off but the actual
reason does make a little bit more sense
in the same way that's sitting on the
lamp somehow it makes sense what you see
he didn't get any life insurance and he
wants to make sure his kids are
financially secured before he goes how
am I gonna support myself and two kids
why did you leave everything to the last
minute if he can go into work as usual
and get the merger to go through okay a
ton of money will be given to him that
he can pass on to his kids making sure
that they'll be okay but um have you
considered this other possibility show
everyone that your fucking goes to make
goddamn millions off of it I mean if you
told that scientist or hell any
scientist that you'll let him study you
if you donate said shit ton of money I
think they would fuckin do it but no it
makes much more logical sense just to go
into work as usual and have his kids
turn off the light so that he can talk
to people no suspicion there what are
they doing ah they're shutting out the
light and even that doesn't make sense
seeing how there's clearly scenes where
you can see light touching him over and
over again I mean Jesus Christ he's in
the lit doorway should half of his face
be gone or something I'm talking about
the fact that I want to concentrate and
the view in the sunshine it's
distracting
okay I'll buy that one so nothing in the
script has given me reason to as an
actress I just decided to give up you
have to take your life insurance
physical this afternoon so the doctor of
course in the dark because when is the
doctor ever needed light tries listening
for his heartbeat
hmm hmm sounds a bit tinny not much bass
in a lot of trouble but aside from that
fine
oops almost forgot the easily excitable
nerd who left face got him rolling in
the aisles on Nick jr. he uses a replica
of Keira Knightley to fake the x-ray and
all that's left is the urine sample give
me a minute
why did she laugh at that do they
usually watch one of urine sample is
done give me a minute I have some issues
some sick creepy Authority alerting
issues so he sneaks in to steal some of
Dana Carvey of turtle man's urine for
the same test because apparently he
never looks down to aim when he does
this kind of stuff
because this is what you think of when
you think of a kids comedy a creepy
shirtless guys and getting disturbingly
close to an old guys junk in the middle
of the bathroom your room a family
picture
thus the fiscal is complete and for some
reason Cosby forgets to put on his mask
and for some reason turtleman is the
only one able to notice that you forgot
and yes he like many would be the first
to be institutionalized due to ghosts
add the chain of suffering had to start
somewhere
everything's all fine and good but they
had to hurry to get ready for this
merger because they only have three days
before he'll start to fade away why
because we can make up any shit that we
want
it's the afterlife and because we don't
know anything about it we can assume
that fucking anything makes logical
sense where are you sure we have to
recreate the entire gameplay of salmon
max hit the road
hey I can't help it if they lost the
paperwork of the afterlife this is the
only way to keep me visible now where's
my Dorothy voice I thought as Max I
didn't have to do that voice can you
address anyone else no but when you
address me yes but critic I just don't
know how we could possibly reenact the
entire game I mean we don't even have a
giant trap to climb into well find a way
critic I don't need her to do salmon max
I can do both voices on my own what's
wrong with my voice stop up up uh now
you have to say like a 1920s paperboy
shouting a headline I thought that I was
doing when you're talking to him as Sam
it's max when we're talking to him as
Malcolm its 1920s paperboy now I'm sorry
rules from upstairs extra extra read all
about it
critics of Bing - hi hi I feel my soul
fading away from that disloyalty
that's better than her max boys shut it
mister uh he's right but critic
apologize to him it's max with the paper
book mmm
go back and forth I get a strong feeling
I'll keep me here longer oh sorry
Malcolm I didn't means it I just wanna
stick it moved on again all of these
bosses apology accepted people think it
to me shut it Sam
and show her how to do a better max
voice right the trick is to get it all
nasally kind of like a flamboyant Bugs
Bunny it's good to be dead
you
The Fool hell's bully gets in the car
with Cosby's daughter and of course not
wanting to raise suspicions he mutilates
his body like a possessed Muppet Oh
now make sure you get nothing but crappy
movies from here and now mr. linguist ah
you are never never ever going to date
that Tommy wrecker is the only guy in
school that knows the man alive and I
will date him if I want to then of
course as is on par with most of this
movie the family in no way tries to
explain the obvious weird shit going on
that obviously needs explaining and I do
not appreciate your interference in my
pathetic social life ah it's her time of
the month that still works on us right
but it's okay because this movie
addresses the important issues that
anyone would be addressing under such
bizarre disturbing circumstances how am
I gonna be a magician at career day
tomorrow without the trunk of doom okay
movie um can I bring you up to date on
something I don't think you're quite
aware of uh
come closer come closer littles little
close blue close okay you listening you
listening you listening hey what is
wrong with you people
death is not some sort of weird
personality trait it's fucking dad the
suspension of disbelief and then the
suspension of just not giving a shit all
of these are just excuses to force what
they think is a funny scenario down our
throats but what they're missing is that
comedy works when you can have something
close to a relatable situation and
nobody fucking nobody would ever be able
to relate with these choices I mean they
just make no sense
it's like saying oh my god America just
blew up well let's go start making cream
cheese you don't think we should do
something else
no the cream cheese seems the most
logical
well I can't see no reason not to let's
do it cream cheese cream cheese hello
yeah yeah oh he's dying man this is Tony
bakery Tony Ricker yeah that's me put
the bitch on because that's what a
teenage boy talking to the parent of a
girl he wants to get with would say put
the bitch on yeah it's like you put a
hidden camera in a real family's house
because you guys are just capturing
reality so well okay are you sure you to
do that are you sure you didn't put a
hidden camera in some family's house and
this is just the recordings that you're
showing us it's so fucking realistic God
movie were you just raised in a burlap
bag being beaten by unfunny DVDs of
Carlos Mencia and then suddenly released
into the world thinking yeah I can
represent the social interactions of a
human animal well let me tell you
something but we come here come here
little closet lyrical lyrical fuck you
so he grabs the boy through the
telephone wires because you can't prove
a ghost can't do that and he scares the
living shit out of it what stop the
bitch you know it just hit me
Cosby in this movie is like a collection
of all the unfunny Tim Allen grunts not
the legitimately humorous ones just the
awkward brand and if you should just
call
so help me out fuck you you know what
this movie is so unpleasant and so nasty
and so uncomfortable
I really am wondering this was meant to
be a legitimate scary film what you are
about to hear is real it has not been
edited or enhanced the subject of some
movies is so disturbing that those who
experience them who never and speaking
of an intelligent his son tries to
perform an escape act which of course
the teacher allow is kelly's probably
distracted by where the fuck he got a
child-size straitjacket and during his
merger Cosby leaves in the middle and
helps him out with his act which seems
to work out well seeing how he lost the
key
hi kid doctors big Minnie you couldn't
leave yeah did what I thought about it
you more important well for the brief
few moments that I'm here I've also
officially lost my job and the insurance
with two kids were yelling at me for it
to begin with but hey what do I care if
you're left in financial ruin at least I
helped you in a career you clearly
showed you're not cut out for how am i
doing you're getting an A but then the
scientist shows up and explains oh I
can't do this shit justice just listen
you're not a ghost what am i you didn't
die you just jumped out of your body
that's all keep listening
it's been rumored there was one other
case in medical years ago before he was
able to find his body and get back into
it poor fella had to uh wear a wear a
bunny costume through me it was
somewhere in Minnesota I think that was
my father
Oh spected this wasn't heredity trait
far out so um if there's any of you out
there that miss that
Oh parently your soul can be scared out
of its body and this is a hereditary
thing passed down from generation to
generation and apparently one of the
ways that you can get your soul back
into your body involves a rabid suit
that you wear for extended period of
time I've never done this before but
that series of sentences is so strange
so bizarre and so troubling to me that I
literally have nothing to say about it
I don't even know what angle to come at
it from I just have a fear that the more
I comprehend what was just said for more
mentally insane I will become so I'm
from my own health as well as yours you
should be fuckin thankful but just that
they're about to go look for his body
his daughter's lips on a cliche which
causes them to take her to the hospital
which of course causes her to leave her
body as well hey I guess it's in the
blood for the midi-chlorians I don't
know whatever the fuck spirit what is
get back into your body before something
serious happens like what don't do this
to me always about you isn't it how
things affect you while I'm thinking of
me right now and this girl's life feels
a lot better than that crappy life I was
having to live and I'm not going back to
it yes again quite clearly understanding
teenagers it captures quite wonderfully
that most teenagers want to be ghosts I
don't question that doing so might have
them wrecker like the bunny suit seen
together but as Cosby starts to fade
away for good guess what they just so
happened to find in the room next door
so insert some Shyamalan bullshit about
how everything happens for a reason and
watch as Cosby coincidentally right next
door reunites with his body
which does suddenly raise the question
for me
did he soon die - was that going to be
some sort of spin-off go suit
how do you feel well pretty fucking
confused seeing how I can see you in the
light even though we clearly established
I shouldn't dedication so wasn't really
ghost dad as much as comatose dad but
hey if they called it that it wouldn't
be nearly as successful and they all
leave to come across a familiar face I
am yours to command
go to hell and sit on a red-hot coal oh
yes yes evil master and he's off to kill
about a dozen more people this film is
dedicated to the lack of common sense
plausibility and anything representing
years of human evolution whenever you
feel bad about yourself just be happy
that you had nothing to do with the
making of ghost it guys this is not only
bad this is fascinatingly bad once in a
while there's an a present of fact given
the time period but overall this is one
of the biggest question marks of
comedies ever
how could anyone think this could work
how could anyone sign onto it how could
anyone read one page of this script and
possibly get a life it's uncomfortable
it's stupid it makes no goddamn sense
whatsoever it is straight up dead on
arrival and I should know being dead
myself actually I'm not I just still
really upset about what they did on
wicker man so I figured this was a very
fitting sort of revenge I think I pulled
it off pretty good didn't I I think a
moment like that calls for a good dream
he figured it out I'll play both Sam and
Max in a terrifying hybrid called
Sandman while I play the girl from their
TV show that no one remembers hey wait a
minute didn't you say that ghosts
couldn't touch things
yes yes I did and yet you are touching
us now that is also correct you lied to
us didn't you right on the money you
never killed yourself affirmative and
you did all of that just to see if we
were dumb enough to do it absolutely no
part of that was false so why are you
just calmly explaining it to us here
because quite frankly you should be
ashamed of yourselves for letting me
take advantage of you like that
a ghost a fucking ghost
you honestly fell for that you are dumb
enough to fall for all the stupid stuff
that I was making up on the top of my
head I mean sexy Dorothy really and look
at you you look like McGruff the Crime
Bunny
shame on you shame on you both now if
you excuse me I am hoping that the guilt
in confusion that you were feeling right
now will buy me some time so I can flee
to my car like a coward so he's not dead
no but he'll wish he was well what are
you doing on funny ears I'll show you
how to do Amex and French and turn the
ball thanks Dorothy
off click your heels three times upside
his head
Oh
my company